someone said you think it's sad that
you're just living because you got a
friend or two it's like I know I
think maybe this I don't know I came to
this realization and someone said that's
really sad I don't think it's sad I
think we live for other people the
things that make life worth living are
others play some Co games we're not
going to do that come on we're not doing
that some Co games I'm not playing with
you I'm good no let's play I'm good
don't be like that no you got to respect
people's boundaries and that's what I
put the boundary that's a no yeah but
you have to learn to compromise no I
don't have to not for that so disclaimer
I'm I might get a little emotional I
might not it's fine don't worry about it
but when I was growing up when I was
growing up man I was a
loser first things first first things
first guys serious video today I was a
loser I was overweight which doesn't
just make you a loser like but in my
school it did and you know I was that
kid that sat at the table with three
other people that were also like the
super rejects that was me and there's
nothing wrong with that that actually is
a good thing for me because I met my
friends that's where I met my friends my
my lifetime friends is where I met at
that table it was like four or five
people and expanded and you know got
Slimmer over time but it was those
people and uh we did everything together
all all my whole life like from
kindergarten up we did everything
together and that was a really cool that
was a really awesome thing that happened
in my life but something happened a
little bit later and when I got to my
late 20s and a lot of you can probably
attest to this in the comments let me
know but when I got to my late 20s those
friends disappeared and it's not because
they were like I hate you Cody it's
nothing like that it's you know life
happens you people get married they move
across the country they were just gone
so you know you know the story about me
anyway I mean if you follow my channel I
got married um I still hung out with my
friends but you know I got married and
she became my best friend and uh in 2016
she didn't want to be my friend anymore
so we were together about eight years
and then she
left so I was totally alone and my
friends were pretty much gone this was
at the point where they were
disappearing and moving away and stuff
like that and over the last couple years
I've came to accept this I'm I thought
to myself hey you know like when you get
to this age you just don't have friends
anymore and it's kind of a hard
realization to come to but it just
seemed normal
everybody my age seems the same and it
just seem that's just seems how it's how
it is nowadays and is it entirely that
bad to have no friends no no I mean it's
gives you time to focus on yourself but
would you need that support uh yeah it
is I think maybe for some people like
very few of you thrive for other people
I think it's just a lot of cope
personally and I'll say this
also you know what it makes me think
of you remember them I I Don't Need No
Man few moments
later I love him it's like these women
who I don't mean no man then they get a
man and and they're like they realize
they realize what they L yeah I'll say
this I thought I didn't need family cuz
I wasn't close to my family for a long
period of my life and now being closer
to my mom and some of my family members
now it's like been lifechanging you
don't realize you need something until
you till you really have it and you like
you and there times of need and you have
people to rely on they're there for you
for special moments you share things
like there's going to be a moment where
you have a flash and you be like oh this
is why people need Community this whole
idea that we're excelling in solitary
confinement and by ourselves is [__]
like I said there might be exceptions to
the rule but the people who I see
generally thrive in life are people who
are surrounded by people that love them
not folks who are by themselves and I
mean almost every study I've ever seen
says like you're going to die earlier
you're going to feel less fulfillment
and less happiness you're much more
likely to take your own life like I want
to say that because I see a lot of
people saying this kind of stuff and I
don't want Folks at my home watching be
like yeah be by yourself with no friends
and nobody it's amazing I don't want you
to feel bad about the circumstance where
you don't have people around you but I
also don't want to lie to you and say
those circumstances are good yeah but I
just didn't have it I'm now 31 years old
guys I'm 31 I do almost everything
myself you know I I do my YouTube the
channel you watch that's pretty much my
entire life please
subscribe it's my entire life guys oh my
God but I learned
something I learned something really
recently that I didn't think I would uh
get to
experience when I started YouTube you
know it was for fun obviously and uh
when it when it started taking off that
was pretty cool
but something came of it that I never
thought would ever come of it my viewers
and I know a lot of people are different
but my viewers would message me and talk
to me and I have people that have been
in my community for a long time and
they've become you know real friends but
now granted that's the point of this
whole video is the fact that I I didn't
consider it that way you know they were
the people from my YouTube Community you
know and the people in my real my in my
actual life you know I don't have any
friends in real life so I talk to these
people on Discord I talked to these
people on Instagram I talked to these
people on Twitter and I talk to them
regularly you know well recently we had
a we had a meet up guys we went to
Orlando with 16 people maybe all from my
channel and um
that's about the probably the first day
of this Meetup with some truly fandam
tastic people about u a day into this
Meetup maybe maybe about a day into it I
learned
something
that
I learned something inadvertently that
I didn't think I would
learn and I learned that these
people that chose
to they chose to come to this get
together with
me
I learned that they were my real
friends I'm
sorry as tou you as this is does this
sound like somebody who sounds like uh
they don't need nobody in their
life that they thriving by
themselves I'm just saying I I've never
watched this video but I didn't know it
would turn out like this but this is
what I'm talking about when you live
without something you think you're fine
and then it hits you and you have like a
wave of
emotions I'm happy for him cuz like you
know you don't expect videos like this
to S seemingly go well but I think
there's a lot of people suffering who
haven't had this Revelation yet and some
who unfortunately may never have it and
that makes me sad I'm fresh I'm fit I'm
authorized and monetized hm when people
look at you they judge you they judge
you on your height they judge you on
your looks they judge you on your smell
and best believe they judgeing you on
your skin now look I'm not talking about
putting on foundation and doing all this
other crazy stuff but it's okay to have
nice smooth skin you like being touched
you like being caressed some of you
don't know what that's like it's okay
someday and that's where today's sponsor
come into play t Henley I got smooth
skin ladies they touch it they be like
oh your skin softer than mine I'm like
yeah it is and listen if you're anything
like me learning about different
products and what you got it's too much
so T Henley makes it simple they got a
level one box you grab it it comes with
instructions inside the box that are
simple to use and you just go through
the process besides amazing skin T
Henley members enjoy 20% off retail
price plus the ability to pause or
cancel at any point during their
membership because TSH h sponsoring
today's video you get 30% off your first
box plus a free gift on us click on the
link below get yourself set to have a
better
skin people judge you on your possession
people judge you on your skin get it now
listen this is your opportunity use
these products start looking fresh and
fit make sure your skin shine like
pearls it just I've always said for
years now that I don't have friends
and it's just crazy to
me I left I left Orlando last week you
know and I got home and I was
just I was just laying there and I
realized that I have
friends real real friends and that's
something I didn't expect to happen and
I told you I was going to probably get
emotional and I actually thought I was
strong enough to hold it back but I'm a
big old fat [__] and I just can't help
it he got me with that one he got me
with that
one
dude he got me with that one that was
pretty good big old fat [__] C [__] I'm
happy for it easy on your [__] I'm Happ
you let out them let out them tears go
ahead cry out thought was about to say
out let out them [__]
tears yeah let all that fat [__]
bad fat [__] tears
yeah it's like it's okay man it's okay
and I get it the realization is really
[__] up though I think he put an x on
that [__] you like you went like man
it's not going to happen and then
[__] hits you
away I got friends he did that Lonnie
Williams I didn't remember that Lon from
the real of course I do of course all
that what he did that [__] without the
Sass yes he did all that [__] without
the say without being glad and
obnoxious broadcasting what was she
saying what you mean I don't need no
man oh no I don't and then it went
like go you can have your
own we have our own I am s
you I don't need a man I don't need a
man but guess what I want you and that's
the
difference the thing that's different
about him is
that it's not about him being better
he's still a man yeah but it's the
Loyalty that I like you know what I mean
it's like I can leave oh and he's there
for
me one friend I was talking to her and
she's like you know I Don't Need No Man
and I have my yeah yeah I don't need a
man I was like girl don't and this is
why I'm so emotional about it because so
many of our sisters are so lonely yeah
and they don't want to admit it and all
they got to do is just take a chance so
I don't want you to live your life
without finding
[Applause]
someone you think you're good what
happen
yeah tour is already [__] lonely you
come back home to loneliness is a bit
[__] it's a bit dry it's a bit dry so
you go you go to Orlando yeah I'm just
going to have some fun anyways I don't
give a [__] I ain't got no friends
anyways what am I going to do I ain't
got no friend and you come back up there
it's like [__]
facts [__] it hit I get you bro yeah but
I get the sentiments and I get the
feeling man you think you don't need
that and you shut that [__] down I think
there's a lot of people and I think it's
become popular in society to be some
kind of Lone Wolf I enjoy myself so much
by myself I think it's perfectly fine to
enjoy your own company and to enjoy do
but when people take it to the extreme
where they act like they don't need
anybody I cringe a little bit forget the
fact that science doesn't back it up or
anything like think about the best
moments in your life and 99% of them are
always going to be things you share with
other people the memories you get to
share like you know what's even better
than great experiences reminiscing with
the people you made those great
experiences with cuz you get to relive
all those emotions every single time and
you get to see the excitement on their
face as they recount to you details that
your own memory forgot mhm so they get
the piece it's almost like you guys both
built a built a little painting then you
guys broke it up into pieces you
thinking you got the whole thing but no
she kept a couple one or he kept a
couple ones and then you guys come back
together and you put it
back if you do it by yourself I promise
you going to forget details it it is
there is something there's nothing like
it there's nothing like it I uh I think
back to even like talking to siblings
about my parents and like things that
happened to my childhood that I forgot
about and they're filling me in and I'm
just like damn and I'm sitting there
having like whole ass moments that keep
me really grounded and present I'm like
oh I'm alive right now you need people
for that you know I love taking trips I
like taking trips about myself you never
want to take trips with the wrong people
but the best trips are always with the
right people
m
the worst trips are with the wrong
people but the best trips are with the
right people I know Community we've
always been communal creatures that's
never going to
change and so I say this I hope you guys
try to Foster these kinds of
relationship in your life I think hope
you make the effort I hope the people
around you try to make the effort in
return I hope you guys fall apart and
then come back together to be even
stronger afterwards cuz God knows my
best relationships I've been like that
up until now this whole Lone Wolf
mentality
it's cool in an anime it's cool in the
movies in real life it [__] sucks cuz
they don't they don't the movies don't
show the bad side of it no yo throughout
my life I've met some people that always
claim that they're long woles through
different aspect of life and every time
I call [__] back then I was a little
bit more confrontational I with just try
to prove them wrong now I just watch a
real Lone Wolf wouldn't talk to me a
real Lone Wolf W
wouldn't do cries of help or need time
and need and it's okay it's not a bad
thing when you tell someone that claim
they're lone wolf that they're not lone
wolves they take it personally like you
you try to say you a little [__] no
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that's not what it is you're looking for
advice you want mentorship you want
people friends around you you want
that's not a lone wolf you like the
aesthetic of a lone wolf you like the
badass Tre of a lone wolf you like
walking away and [__] exploding back in
the back of you but that's Hollywood the
aesthetic looks good they don't show you
how lonely and depressive it is I'll say
I'll go a step further brother if you're
truly a lone wolf you're not watching
this video you're not watching this
video you're being alone doing your lone
thing yeah you probably in the woods in
some cabin somewhere I got people who
trying to convince me they lone wolves
they spend all their days watching
streamers eating their food while while
they're watching you're not alone you're
not alone you got some you know
interesting form of connection with you
know a par of social thing but it's okay
but you're not alone but you're not
alone you in Discord communities
chatting it up anonymously you're not
alone you're getting those dopamine Rush
from interacting with people differ
you're on YouTube comment sections
leaving [__] or but I I disagree you're
trying to connect with people are youone
are you a lone wolf or you just don't
want to go out there yeah you want you
want Tik toks browsing the whole
day why cuz you don't want to be with
yourself
[Laughter]
you don't want to be alone with this yo
but you feel you know you feel alone I
we all feel alone sometimes it's just
crazy it's crazy to me
that on this weird thing of the internet
that you can start over so I want to
read something from a boy uh scotx he
was at to get
together I'm going to read this and um I
want you guys to pay attention because
this is how I feel so we're going to
read this real quick oh my heart's
beating so fast I apologize guys that
wasn't what I was supposed to do well
you're the first one to get this cuz
you're definitely included I had lots of
thinking time on the drive already um so
read this and pass it along it says so
now that the trip is done the one from
last week well for most of us I just
wanted to say thank you you really don't
know just what it means to me 7 months
ago I was staring down the barrel of my
pistol hating my life and squeezed the
trigger hard enough that a trimmer would
have ended my life I'm not sure what
stopped me I wound up watching Cody and
then Hannah which is tiny one Badger
every night to keep me from thinking
about it and it's led me to this entire
community that has literally turned into
my
family I know my humor isn't the best
I'm kind of a dick same and my social
skills are jack [__] because in 37 years
I've had exactly two friendships that
weren't whatever because of the horrible
relationship I was in for that I'm sorry
but I'm trying I was so hesitant on
coming on this trip and I'm so glad I
did you folks have not only saved my
life but keep me looking forward and
improving I'm thankful for each and
every one of you and I can't wait for
the next trip and I can't wait either
big big Mike sent that to me the other
day and I read that and I lost I lost my
[__]
because I guess you don't really think
about it the what I get from the
community is like the same that some of
them get from me and that's just it's
just it's comforting to have you know
it's comforting to know that we all feel
similar some of us do so one more thing
one more thing so this thing right here
we went on an ax throwing Adventure it
was awesome I enjoyed it I won the
tournament cuz you guys suck no it's
fine don't worry about it but we have a
few more people that weren't actually at
this thing but it was awesome we had a
lot of fun um and it's just cool it's
real cool to learn that there's
like-minded people out there and it's
cool for the first time in a long time
to realize that I I I actually have
friends so I can't no longer legally say
that I don't have friends because I do
okay all right well I thought that was
heartwarming it was cool reading that um
yeah some people are really one friend
away from taking their own
life crazy to think some people just
they
feel that alone and
isolated someone said you think it's sad
that you're just living because you got
a friend or too like I know I
think maybe this I don't know I came to
this realization that someone said
that's really sad I don't think it's sad
I think we live for other people I'm not
saying you just sit here and you
self-sacrifice all the time but I'm
saying like the things that make life
worth living or others for most of us
it's our parents it's our kids at some
points it's maybe both as you transition
in life it's the friends it's your
community
work
um like someone said AB would you want
to you know if you on an island with
every toy ever world you like I would
offer myself in like a year or two and
what's the point Point like everything I
love at least in my life involves others
going out dancing others playing video
games co-op games are the best like uh D
and D I do that with others I I to do
everything I enjoy and that brings me
joy you know sitting down with homies
and making food like I love cooking but
I don't like cooking for myself I like
cooking for
others like the things that are the best
are other people I like taking pictures
I don't like taking pictures of myself I
like taking pictures of others
everything that I ever loved was about
other people oh I but you're dependent
on yeah whatever [__] it is that wimpy
or whatever [__] you I don't care maybe
it is I don't give a [__] I think it's
amazing it makes me happy it makes the
people around me happy and it gives me a
sense of purpose and that's a beautiful
thing and I just hope that everyone
watching finds that even if it's only a
few people in your life even it's only a
few Hobbies I just hope that you guys
get to discover the joy of other people
that's all I want to
say
your turn you said a lot so I just be
yapping that's fine yappity Yap y it's
just that yeah you said a lot and you
know I don't want toeat what you said
there nonsense to that
but the Lone Wolf
thing most of you aren't but I'm not
fighting y'all anymore yall can't you
can't be aone wolf I could see you in
that cabin just like eating bears with
your hands got my I got I got my Lone
Wolf moments okay there sometime I take
my vest off and I'm not associated with
a group and I just go at night do my
thing I'm alone on a bike I got my
people when I ride with them and I got
them but there's sometimes I take my my
my my RO sometimes I go to the
restaurant alone true sometimes but
because my life is with a lot of people
in general I need that balance of being
alone it doesn't mean that I am alone
Lone Wolf no I need my alone time that
don't mean I'm a lone wolf I would not
say I'm a lone wolf any every time
that's not true I like my friends my
family I love to cook I bought the house
that I bought to have people over yeah
when you invited us over you never want
to go to My Hood I've been there once
you once exactly yeah yeah yeah this
[__] I somebody would call the
police on me cuz the houses were so big
not going to lie I would walk around
like yo is it legal for us [__] to be
here yo they like black people on this
St crazy that's the thing so I bought
that to have all them people so yeah but
yeah of course you play online games and
[__] my games are always alone oh man
you got to try Co-op gam no [__] that
[__] tell I Co-op every day you stay
here I'm telling you no no we're good
let's play video gam we're good no we
already have played video games play we
play Among Us Co up no no that's that's
that's who you want to play that nerd
[__] no no there's some good stuff what
we can find some Shooters you like
shooting guns right of course yeah I got
you we can shoot some guns okay play
some Co games we're not going to do that
come on we're not doing that some Co gam
I'm not playing with you I'm good no
let's play I'm good don't be like that
no you got to respect people's
boundaries and that's what I put the
boundary that's a no yeah but you have
to learn to compromise no I don't have
to not for that I come relas I
compromise a bunch of [__] and you do
too then now let's let's put it at that
yeah and I'm asking you to make one more
com I'm asking you to give me a second
chance no biggie I'm not
what okay but
yes okay I get what we say yeah but
anyways it is what it is that's all I
got to say all right let us know what
you guys think in the comments below do
you guys want to see us play some co-op
games I'm not playing with him I'm not
playing with him out yo we go to your
place for lunch no I'm not no I don't no
no play Fletch no we're not we're not
doing that why not no not doing that you
said I never want to come eventually
we're going to do that [__] we're going
to invite all the [__] to go to my
players and that's that eventually
eventually why but we're not playing
games we don't have to play games yeah
we don't we don't have to we won't we we
can try we play fighting game like this
we're
not all